you use playing with pistols and getting
money in the street then that's probably
what you're going to talk about you know
and
and if you know
eating [ __ ] and and having three sims
was you
was you what you was doing on leisure
that's going to come out too in the
music
shout out to you
what's the most amount of uh women at
once
that mayno's had at one time um
not that six maybe six yeah so a
sevensome technically are you that's the
seventh summer are you the seventh or
the fifth yeah that's the seven that's
that's
you know maybe five between five and i
want to say five or six
so a six or seven something definitely
five though i can't remember i can't
figure out if it was
so when you're [ __ ] five chicks yeah
it's a lot of work obviously the girls
got to be handling each other as well
because there's only so much it's not
fun all the way i was going to say like
it almost feels like more work than it
is is is it was it worth is it fun i
guess is my question
or is it kind of like yes a lot of that
[ __ ] is like eat your ego
your appetite your mind you have to look
at food and be like yo
i want that and your eyes is doing more
than what your stomach can hold every
day so it's kind of like
you know
that the thought and idea of having all
these women
at one time sounds amazing it sounds
crazy it's just
it's just wow
you know and so i mean
it works
you made it work it works it happens but
all that's just
you know
um that's just
leisure do you make sure the girls know
each other first like are they all
homies is that healthy this doesn't
happen all the time i don't i don't want
to show you the one time it did happen
give me the scenario oh how you
convinced six chicks to [ __ ] you at the
same time yeah they they uh
damn i'm trying to think it was if it
was five or six you got like one chick
who like wrangles them all up let's just
say it was five okay five
oh good number i was i was out
i had a girl that used to
like to have girls around all the time
she had some girls and it was just one
girl that we didn't know
and um
i want to say
yeah it was one girl that we didn't know
and then we bought her around and you
know yeah i mean girl see the thing
about women is that they click easier
than men
this is true you know especially girls
who are kind of like right they're
friendly right at each other they they
they really uh
by curious right so they they click
quicker than [ __ ] do like you all you
need is alcohol
some hookah
some hookah yeah and they clicking
some booze and somebody
who's in local that's it
from there it's off to the right
they're clicking hey how are you man
over there yeah i know
oh you know what's the name oh what's
your page
they they following each other and then
turning around and kissing
wow this is this is yeah
it's amazing this is life
you know
i'm just trying to think how like
physically like that would work that's
like an orgy loki
that's like pretty much what it is some
real pharaoh [ __ ] though for my king
[ __ ] it doesn't happen every day that's
not regular once a lifetime i mean like
two is what's a lifetime solid two is
regular two's regular for you it's
regular for anybody how many
i don't know about for anybody two is
regular for any that's really regular
girls give me the over under on how many
threesomes you think you've had in your
entire life that's what's that number
this is this north of 50
under 50
definitely more than 50. you've had more
than 50 threesomes of course that's not
that's that's pretty regular like that's
pretty standard
standard it's a standard standard mano
[ __ ] that's not it's not about me it's
about you no it's not about me that's
not standard
you serious
y'all bugging y'all you're bugging no
you're bugging no you're bugging that's
standard 50
i've had a handful of those situations i
said what's a handful less than
okay more than five less than ten
somewhere in that range now you're north
of fifty standard brother like that's i
mean we talking about
we talking them we talking about
uh
though okay so okay okay let's do the
math here so if you've had more than 50
threesomes
on the low end that's 100 chicks
are we knocking on
are you mayno chamberlain damn i can't
what you know what north of a thousand
chicks in your life let me
i'm not gonna say that would you say
more or less than a thousand i'm not
gonna say anything listen what i'ma say
is this i mean you already put a number
of threesomes no
is 50 a lot of three times it's just it
happened 50 times this is what you're
saying
yeah 50 different threesomes
but this that's the amount of time
that's me some girls might be the same
some cast members in these three sims
might have stayed consistent right okay
right okay that's what i'm saying
right exactly
so here's the thing
that's in like 15 how long i've been
home
what year did you come home 2003.
so that's 19 years ago
that's crazy okay so this is an
expanse of 19 years so is that that many
is that it's not that much i mean i'm 35
and it's not that much
listen i respect it